the difference between somebody who's
loyal to their wife and somebody who is
not is not the fact that they might have
their eye get caught is that happens
they're human you're going to have
emotions right the difference between
somebody who's loyal not is whether they
cheat right and so I think that the same
thing with patients the same thing with
honesty it's not do you want to lie it's
do you choose not to despite wanting to
lie and it's just like courage it's not
the absence of fear but taking action
despite it and so we think that we need
to feel a certain way in order to be a
patient person or be a kind person or
whatever when at least in my experience
it's been you don't feel that way and
you take the action that a patient or
kind or courageous or loyal or honest
person would take despite the feeling